Let's continue to briefly introduce the new features of System 4.
First, the new built-in library and the library with expanded functions are listed
. In the
system, the built-in modeling standard library is
version 3.  Updated to point 2.1
This bar
always contains new libraries and components that can be used in digital circuit composite signal heat diffuser models,
for example digital libraries for digital electronics with
sinusoidal currents and electricity using voltage.  Mouth Eisai Stationary Library for efficient circuit
modeling There is a fundamental wave library for modeling the electric knight of the grass
.
There is also a translation when the low stop of the human weak library is updated, but there is
also thermal port support.
Now it's profitable and it's now possible to express heat loss in an increasingly convenient way. What can this be done
with this new library and packing sister?
For more information, please see our web page that introduces usage examples by industry. In
system model A4, a new system library
store is introduced, and
paid and free model libraries can be additionally downloaded and automatically installed.
All of these libraries have been tested and tested on system 4 and
we will continue to work with
developers to provide new and updated
libraries.  We will continue
to strive to ensure that these libraries are easy to use
with high quality documentation.The libraries currently available in the store are hydraulic and smart
cooling libraries
and bio-combined system dynamic sprayers.  There are Mechanics libraries
.
The slides below briefly introduce the main functions and uses of each library
. As
I mentioned earlier, the usage examples of these libraries are industry-specific usage examples.
You can also see it on our web page that we introduce. There
are also examples of direct access from the library store.
The hydraulic library is
a good library designed to model hydraulic type, for example aircraft automobile heavy equipment process industry. It
includes cylinder tank pipe and various hydraulic components.
Smart cooling library is also a paid library
.  For example, it is a library for efficiently modeling the cooling system of automobiles, heavy machinery, aircraft, etc. It
includes child components such as cooling fan pipeline, pump heat exchanger, etc. The
library store also includes many free libraries.
In the case of the new version, the smoke library is
used for modeling simulation visualization of biochemical reaction networks.
This library can be applied to systems biology and fields where morning ritual drugs are fat.
Includes components commonly used in personality models such as drugs in the regional compartment version of which
this library can be used to import or export
models defined in the bml Systems Biology Markup Langedge into the
system modeler.  You can also
use this library as an example of the pharmacokinetic model for the mri contrasting agent you see
.
This model is used to perform simulations and to examine the differences between patients with pulmonary fibrosis in various disease states.
Can
Planer Mechanics Library is also one of the free libraries
This library was developed primarily for use in mechanical engineering classes
.
This library
focuses on the two-dimensional cavalry bottom.  Damper
Nrotary joint
Includes packing net for vehicle models, etc.
Let's take a look at the model of the pendulum and slider mechanism as an example of using this library
.
Finally, I would like to introduce you
to the
system dynamics library, which, as
the name implies
, is based on the public relations theory of systems biology.
Included, for
example, in the power market
used to build social technology models such as disease radio distribution
systems  This model, which shows the spread of influenza virus in the population, is
one example of the use of this library.
So far, the system related to the library has also seen the new functions of Temple 4, and
other important new functions are in the model center and simulation center.
Improved user interface
Structure that organizes model parameters into groups and tabs
More advanced control of simulation settings Now
you can select objects in dimensional animation, etc. In
addition, the snow shop model A4 has a user interface and documents.  Many of the centers have been
translated into Japanese As
I mentioned earlier, the Document Center also contains
built-in resources such as video tutorial modeling tips, user guide libraries and component documentation
Delica by Tiller.  You can also see Guzampuru here
You can also search directly with the topic library model using the search field
System Modeler 4 also has expanded connectivity and deployment options,
especially for models using fmi.  It is important that export is now supported
smi is a newly developed industry standard interface specification for exchanging different tools biting models,
thanks to exporting system modeler models to many other software systems.
The integration between mathematica, my name is system modeler, has also been improved. It includes functions that can automatically create a system modeler
model from Tika's equations and control system models, as
well as many new features
within mathematica.  Model diagrams are now used as a visual representation of system modeler objects
in.
Diagrams can also be used with other mathematica graphics
or animated to show management behavior
.  And the range date and integration with mathematica are explained in more detail in another video and
can be found on the web. Finally,
I would like to briefly summarize what we have seen so far.
New features in Mathematica 4 include a built-in updated library and a
new library add-on library,
which can also be accessed from the system's live library,
user interface and overall in the Model Center and Simulation Center.
High performance and new document center added You can now
also export fmi and use it in the software tools you have deployed your model in. It is
deeply integrated with mathematica
These new features  Please use it all
. Thank you for your attention.